[Musique]
Je pense que ça marche oh wow il aime ça
alors ne les publiez pas dessus il y avait une
machine en grande partie evanka perforce mo machine donc
donc aucun pouvoir de légitimité sur une
promotion payez la protection de votre parti c'est
pour vous dire exactement comment va le
padishah  équipe ouais je pense que je pense que les
Chinois doivent être vus pour jouer une
mesure critique beaucoup plus longue en
reconstruisant dramatiquement un pays au
cours du dernier pas de problème donc je pense que
je pense que l'Europe qui était Nixon LaFrance
Ocotillo están de Mexico Quattro gast
heeft een le blanc Avignon  le réalisateur
Panetta passe en revue le prochain domaine